hello i'm dillard dicken and i'll be
talking about my project that i
conducted
during my um omixlogic research
fellowship program and the title of my
project was radiation threats to humans
in space and an alternative approach
with probiotics
my project was focused on spacetime
reading
a type of ionizing radiation called high
led radiation
is
[Music]
i
said and other organs we can gauge um
the effects and treatments using this
method
um
and three
and i have four types of radiation
ranging from point one to
one
so there's zero gy 0.1 gy 0.25 gy and
1gy radiation
the outputs we generated using the 25065
pipelines we
got the shadow index graph
and the channel index
this graph
in the results section figure 2a
has
the figure 2b graph which is the
phylogenetic analysis
and you can see especially for otuc four
and five
the uh
abundance of spotus has decreased
especially for 0.1 and 0.25 gy at 10
days
so to confirm this
test
in an anova test
right that's um
reiterating the results from the
phylogenetic analysis
i found out that otu 3 4 5 and 8
decreased ot abundances
gui at 10 days specifically and i also
found out that for there is no
correlation between the days and the
amount of radiation that
these
mice were exposed
then to find which species these ot us
belong to
i use the jgi website to identify my
otus
and i found out they that they belong to
lactobacillus and by for the bacterium
species these two species have protein
coding genes in the carbohydrate pathway
gobo which is vermont minor butyric
between the central nervous system and
has effects on depression and anxiety
since the anterior dendritic nerve and
the legs nerves connect the back to the
brain
we can prevent a decrease in the
abundance of these two species of
viscosity
of bacteria
will cause a decrease in kaaba
and in return might be a factor in
depression
and as we all know uh one of the common
disorders that are found inside this
when they return
from the iss is depression anxiety
the solution that can be used to
overcome this however is quite simple
and
non-invasive using probiotics rich in
lactobacillus by the bacteria
so i would like to thank um
emilia brotzky
dr mohit mazundar and dr harpy koher for
all of their help in
being um
my
for being
so kind
and during my research fellowship
so um thank you i hope you like
my project and
have a nice day